what is your name how do i pronounce it
it's
tabonique uh-huh where did you grow up
tiffany where are you from
torres california
what was your childhood like you had mom
and dad growing up as a kid
um
i never
i never really got to see my mom and dad
too often
that was kind of like off and on
who raised you when you were young
my grandmother
my grandma
how would you describe your childhood
i really didn't have a childhood
well i was kind of like
always in my own world
did you enjoy school
how far did you go in school
not four
five
i still i still made all 12 grades
but i didn't graduate
right after you're done with school
did you live on your own or you were
still with your
grandmother
still with my grandma
how old are you now
i'm 39
[Music]
and you're living on the street now
yeah
how long have you been living homeless
for like five years
how do you support yourself now
[Music]
well i'm on social security
are drugs part of your life today
what drugs do you play around with
any car
do you think the uh tell me about the
growth on your cheek
when did that appear
it just started growing like a few years
ago
is it painful
[Music]
i'm sure it's getting bigger and bigger
have you seen a doctor about it
yeah
what did the doctor say
they just give me medicine and tell me
to come back
[Music]
yeah there are clinics right here right
around the corner that you can go to and
probably get that taken care of
or looked at for sure
maybe when we're done here i'll take you
over there
[Music]
no what i'm sorry
you don't want to go to see a doctor
not today
[Music]
do you have any friends
is your grandmother still around
has she seen you lately
not rightly
are you concerned about
this growth on your cheek
[Music]
are you concerned about this growth
[Music]
are you afraid of the surgery or are you
afraid of
what it might be yeah
i'm sure it's got to affect your ability
to get a job or to take care of
you know
support yourself or even make friends
[Music]
do you have kids of your own
no
never married
so the reason you're
avoiding going to a doctor is just
because you're afraid that
what you might find out about this
this on your cheek
no i'm just
i'm just scared of the whole process
i'm sure it's
scary but it's got to be even more scary
to to not do anything about it
and find out where it's going to go from
here
if it's untreated
can you see that maybe
avoiding facing what this might be is
potentially going to cause problems
is a drug use just kind of like a way to
not
deal with it
yeah
if you get high you don't really have to
look at it
no
let me run you by one of these clinics
and see if
maybe you can just take a quick look at
it
you don't have to stay if you don't want
at least i can take you past one and
maybe they can give you some quick
advice
already being trickling
i'm sorry
i've been to all the clinics down here
yeah and what why why have you not had
any treatment
i supposed to be going to get it checked
out on monday
this is right around the corner it's
just two days from now
where do you stay now you're in a tent
or you're just living on the street
if somebody's garage
what's your what's your biggest fear
right now
are you afraid that this might be
something serious
no
so
let me run you by one of these clinics
and see if maybe they can't
shed a little bit of light on what's
going on with you
all right
no it's all right
do you have any appointment on monday
though
okay
all right well thank you so much for
talking with me
and i hope you get that
checked out
on monday
i wish you the best of luck with it
you